you
you know most of the people who come to
me is smart so I don't really ever think
that that's going to be an issue but I
really look for people who have this
spark of enthusiasm and the passion yeah
because people are passionate usually
work twice as hard as those who are not
so they need to be hard and hardworking
that's a well I think in science you
have to be hard-working yeah you know if
you see the competition now you realize
everybody else in science is absolutely
working flat out most of the time and
everybody else is pretty smart and so if
you want to compete with them and you
also have to be pretty smart and to work
hard too
you